yeah so that was your first big mish and
then what but that was out of kuwait
that was adequate yep and then what
happened then we moved up into
baghdad we had a little camp set up out
there we called it camp posey you know
we had a
i don't know if you know posey but a
good warrant officer vietnam dude yeah
yeah good
like good stories man the best and we
had another guy we called him ranger and
uh those two dudes came in they helped
build out the camp you know we took a
ranger with us on uh
on quite a few missions good dude and
then we just started operating out of
posey into
baghdad yeah we're right there at the
baghdad international airport and what i
was impressed with
looking back what i am impressed at
looking back is
you guys were freaking super proactive
in getting
missions started like you guys were
super proactive in forming relationships
and and getting the intel that you
needed from various sources
and and starting to do a lot of
operations yeah we
set the foundation for you guys you guys
came in and did like
four times more than what we did but we
were definitely laying that foundation
and one of the things we had our tash
unit senior enlisted leader
um he was dialed in and he came from
damn neck
and so he had a lot of good
relationships and you know
you know damn nick was over there at
that point and so he was tied in with a
lot of the three letter agencies
which opened up the door with quite a
few missions
shared intelligence so that really
helped set that up that foundation for
us
and then from there we're starting to
get you know some good missions and hell
even if you're getting one mission
you're like all right we're good to go
you know because you think
we all think we're gonna be out of there
within six seven months like the whole
thing's shutting down yeah
um but obviously it didn't yeah so
what was your you guys got in some gun
fights too yeah what was it what was the
first one like what do you remember
our first shootout was kind of funny we
were dialing in our
standard operating procedures for a
shootout
um which we hadn't done like you know we
went through training training was good
but it was nowhere near the level that
you know we provided our guys once we
got over to trade it wasn't anywhere
near that
so we identified a few of the gaps we
had and we went we developed we brought
on the platoon we brought in
guys with experience and we developed
our standard operating procedure for
what we're going to do
inside a house if we get in a shootout
and it was basically suppressed fire
cover crash maneuver using a cover and
move we're going to deploy some crashes
someone's going to be
suppressing fire while all that's
happening so on this particular mission
we went in and uh
the house the guy marked for us was the
wrong house we didn't know that we want
imagery everything looked dialed in
tight and they
mark it it looks good we go in breached
the door so we gone explosive so now the
neighborhood's starting to wake up we
clear the house i kept everything on the
clock we clear the
you know two-story house in under two
minutes and we get the call on the net
hey reset
the actual target houses down the street
so we
reset reconsolidate you know one's on
the left twos on the right
gear check you know sensitive equipment
check everyone's good
come back out of the house grab our wood
ladders patrol back down the road
and the right house is marked and we go
up there and it was the right house it
had a double security screen door we go
explosive on it we got a
a failed breach so now it's turning into
a big construction project
guys are up not to mention just so
everybody knows like
after you hit the first house everybody
in a two mile square radius knows what's
happening and if you're in that
neighborhood you know exactly what's
happening
so if you're a bad guy in that
neighborhood you
are now alert and ready to be attacked
and you're prepping yep exactly so
now we've got a fail breach we're on the
outside of the structure
the preachers are working through
getting through that heavy security
screen door
um we're kind of raking windows we're
deploying crashes in there to keep
people away from the front door we
finally get entry
clear the first floor everything's good
we're dialed in and back then we always
pressed into our guys hey
you make the call if you stack on the
stairs you're the number two guy you got
three or four more guys behind you make
the call and go up the stairs we don't
want to just
have this lag period where you're
waiting for me or the oic to make a
decision to tell you what to do
decentralized command
so the guys stack on the stairs i'm
right there i just came out of the the
kitchen area they start moving up the
stairs and there's
young kid upstairs with an ak-47 so he's
like 10 feet away and he's just full
auto
and our guys are on the stairs they're
trying to return fire but the volley's
just all around our dudes man
um i'm yelling at the guys get back down
here they come back down the stairs
and then we go through our shootout
procedures which which pay dividends
they work
we couldn't shoot get at the guy because
the guy's on the second deck and now
we're down below him
so there's no way to get the direct fire
so our guys are exposing themselves a
little bit trying to get an angle here
guys are deploying crashes we deployed
about five six crashes
there's no more gunfire we're like all
right check um
we're going up so you know we go up the
stairs the kid had actually dropped his
gun we clear this
uh the second deck there's freaking
smoke everywhere so it was just
i mean we're gagging there's so much
smoke in the house um
go up there the guy's not there we're
like where the hell did this guy go and
um our guys go out on the on the
on the deck patio and they're clearing
and now we're looking really hard like
where is this guy
and the kid is a young kid hiding behind
curtains and you know the guy's there
and then
boom our guys muzzle strike the guy get
him into the center of the room
we cuff him up and that was that so
did anyone get hit by him by the bad guy
you know
our guy heading up the stairs first the
first guy up he had a grazer over his
mvgs
um it actually hit his his mount um but
he didn't get hit
it was like it was a total pulp fiction
pulp fiction scenario
yeah like he had angels on his because
that could have been a bad night we had
two three guys hitting that one volley
and no one got hit we
we were extremely lucky how many how
many rounds do you think the guy shot
one mag or two mags
did he get a reload no no he didn't get
a reload i think he got a full mag off
somewhere in between 25 and 30 rounds
damn dude
yeah from 10 feet yeah yep close
it's close yeah i mean i don't know how
he he probably missed because he was on
full auto you know
those things yeah you're just bouncing
all around when you go on full auto
um in the dude you know the guy was just
a total douche bag that shot at us to
him he's like i love george bush i love
coca-cola and you're like you
just shut up man so yeah we cuffed them
up and that was
that was emotional when you're getting
shot at that close and you're dealing
with a bad dude that just tried to kill
you you know those uh emotions get
jacked up pretty high
um we had some good teammates here i
mean i was i wanted to kill the dude
um but you we can't do that you know as
much as you want to
you're gonna it's not gonna be good but
we got them cuffed up took them over
to our detention facility and you know
the guys did good that night and they
did good because of
the training the talk throughs that we
did going through the checklist going
through
multiple rehearsals every time these
missions came up
all that panned out all that
worked in our favor for that one event
for that one shootout that all worked
for us you know